[Music]
Kendra delighted to meet you thank you
for doing this today thank you so much
for having me rich it's a pleasure to be
here I get hit up pretty regularly with
people you know pitching this person or
that person or pitching themselves and I
would say 99.9% of those I just dismiss
but you even emailed me some time ago
and you shared the link to the
uninterrupted video which I watched
right away and I was like wow yeah like
this is definitely a person I want to I
want to know more about yeah I knew
immediately that you'd be a great guest
for the show and I think your story is
amazing and powerful and courageous and
I'm honored to be able to help you share
it here today yeah thank you so much I
like I said you know kind of came into
awareness of yourself about four or five
years ago and and you know an avid
listener of the podcast and just with
this whole story coming out just
thinking about you know how I want to
share the story and kind of the the
corners of you know society I wanted to
reach and and just sort of the type of
you know content that you put out I was
like yeah reach out to rich what's
what's the worst season to say no all
right I just not not remind sounds like
shooters got shoot right yeah I was like
I'll just see what happens and then yeah
you know let me back and I actually
first you were like hey you want you
back on Twitter and I was like oh god I
didn't see an email there wasn't like it
didn't show up or whatever there was
like a glitch I was like oh and then I
was like oh yeah I think something
happened yeah yes I was like having a
panic moment no I'm glad that like I
tweeted you as well because I wouldn't
have known that that yeah I didn't go
yeah and I was like well I guess Kendra
changed your line but yeah I was like
yeah just yeah it's just super honored
and grateful to be here so cool
in the beginning of the video the I
think the first thing you say is like
I'm not sure where to begin with this
story and I feel like I'm in the same
place like I'm not sure where to begin
with that but I guess we can begin at
the beginning I mean or maybe just
explain a little bit about who you are
and kind of provide a little context for
yeah so you know former professional
golfer been an athlete my whole life
played basketball the University of
Oregon he got drafted in the NBA yeah
what was his nickname the cowboy yeah
yeah Doug cowboy little so he got that
he got that nickname because so back in
late 60s early 70s they didn't have a
3-point line so and he would always be
shooting like these long shots and his
coach the time was like you know in
practice like hey cowboy take that shot
back to the rodeo
so because it's like you know why are
you shooting from so far out if there's
no three-point line so right kind of
music he was ahead of his time
yeah exactly tagging is in matric so
yeah just you know athletics is sorta in
my blood and I'm an older brother and
older sister who were both athletes and
so athletics really played you know a
big part of my life you know growing up
I always you know growing up figured you
know I'd you know every not every kid
but most kids grow up you know oh yeah I
want to be a professional athlete or
whatever the case is and fortunately had
two older siblings that kind of you know
pushed me around and yeah and kind of I
think you know brought my athleticism to
a different level so sports always you
know they have been a big part of my
life and so I you know played basketball
and golf all throughout high school and
was gonna play basketball in college as
well but ended up just playing golf and
played golf in college at the University
of Oregon and then turned pro and my
life is you know just kind of revolve
around athletics you know basically
since I was five or six years old so
well with a dad named cowboy yeah
exactly if there was too much choice no
exactly that's exactly right I you know
I and what's funny is actually none of
my family really play golf so my brother
did a little bit but they never gone the
neighborhood my dad never pushed
basketball on me that was something that
was always saying I really enjoyed and
but golf ended up being you know kind of
what I stuck with so yeah so you grow up
as a girl raised as a girl identify as
female today as well right so I want to
get all of this correct yes straight
yeah yeah it's somebody who you know was
born in 1966 you know I don't want to I
don't want to fall down the rabbit hole
of like old man syndrome and I realized
there's a lot of nuance and complexity
to this so I
I very much want to like get this
correct so if I miss state something
please let me so the first thing person
you need to know is like for me
personally I'm super lucky about all
that like I and throughout this whole
process and kind of like self-discovery
I like just growing up I'd get mistaken
for you know a guy like you know not all
the time but it would happen and it was
something that was like so mortifying so
just you know I would avoid like you
know social you know interactions or
events to avoid you know that happening
and since this whole thing is you know
transpired it's like I don't
doesn't I don't care anymore right like
I know you know it's like I've owned Who
I am and I you know I love myself for
who I am and it was never about anyone
else or anything else it was always you
know on the inside and once I kind of
figured that out it was like oh okay if
someone was takes me for a guy cool
whatever but it's been a journey to get
to that point yeah oh yeah yeah yeah it
is very interesting
just sitting across from you looking at
you because you are the manifestation of
both female and male like there's
aspects of your face and your physique
that are very feminine and also aspects
that are masculine there and it's
fascinating
I hope that's not like I say that with
love no absolutely I love it like you're
a beautiful person it's it's a very
compelling interesting yeah look that
you have yeah thank you a pose that you
strike yeah thank you so much and that's
like I think growing up because I found
out you know at kind of weird age at
like 12 13 right when like puberty
puberty is hitting like they you know
back then what was it like mm yeah about
2000 2001 and like a lot of knowledge
has that come you know into the fray you
know like in the last 10 or 15 years but
and this is still common practice it's
like oh we'll just you know we're just
gonna raise her as a girl and that's um
you know and that's you know we're gonna
put her on you know estrogen treatment
and gonna raise her as a girl and so for
my you know when I found this out my
entire life I just tried to throw myself
in the female box so hard and just like
and that's why
you know getting mistaken for a guy was
always so painful or whatever is because
I was in my own head forcibly trying to
put myself in that female box and rather
than embracing my you know diverse
genetic makeup you know so the first
real pivotal moment though comes at 12
or 13 when you have this doctor's
appointment so walk me up to that point
like prior to that was there some gender
confusion or were you convicted and
being a girl it was there some sense
that there I mean what was the reason
that you went to go see this doctor and
what happened right so I mean you know
kind of when you're your earliest
memories you know as as when you're
you're a kid you know six seven years
old you know that's kind of for me at
least like my first you know things when
I look back on and think about like how
you feel that's when I first remember
knowing or feeling that something was
different but at that age you're you're
just so like your idea of the world is
so basic and so you know minimal you
don't really like know what to make of
it so I always knew something was
different about myself even before you
know I found out that I was born
intersex and I could never you know put
my you know finger on it I could never
you know figure out what it was I would
you know I'd be in school and you know
I'd have my friends that were guys and
friends that were girls and I could you
know relate to you know both of them in
different ways but also kind of feel
like not really like fully be able to
relate and so that was always something
I you know I felt from a young age and
didn't know what it meant um so um you
know um yeah it's like twelve or
thirteen you know you're going into
middle school you have to have your you
know physical for sports or whatever the
case was so going for a physical and the
the nurse you know you do live the whole
you know body examination and she could
tell that my body wasn't developing it
you know as a typical female would and
she's like okay we need to we need to
check this out when you guys see what's
going on and so go up to OHSU which is a
very reputable hospital up in poor
and yeah that's when I that's when I
discovered or they discovered through
ultrasound and blood tests and all that
stuff that I was born with androgen
insensitivity syndrome right so explain
what a is is so a is is a condition
there's there's like three different
conditions and it's intersex is like a
big like umbrella term for people that
are not born with and you know the
typical gender binary depending on you
know what's inside their body right it
can mean a lot of different it can take
you a long time yeah and they say it's
like one in two thousand which is true
but AIS is more like I don't want to
misquote this but it's something like
one in two hundred thousand so it's it's
pretty rare but that still means there's
tens of thousands of people walking
around exactly so in it so it can mean
different things so for me I was born
without any female reproductive parts
any you know female internally you know
sexual reproductive parts I was born
with male reproductive ports
reproductive parts in internally so
that's essentially but it was not
evident when you were born exactly so
and that's where it can kind of it can
kind of you know differ so sometimes
it's detectable at birth sometimes it's
not sometimes it's not detected until
puberty which was the case for me and
what's really not a good thing and
there's doctors are still doing this is
these babies that they detect you know
are born intersex are assigning genders
to these babies before you know they
grow up and are able to decide for
themselves who they want to be and so
you have these kids who are growing up
and sometimes you know the parents won't
even let them know that this happened
and Atilla grow up and be like I I don't
feel right something's you know
something's different I don't identify
with you know my gender and then they
come to find out that they were born
intersex and we're assigned a gender as
an infant so yeah well we live in a
binary dualistic society I mean you're
born there's a birth certificate and
there's two boxes right so you gotta
check one of those yes exactly
yeah and that's yeah Matt that's
changing
I was just I was just telling Daniel
that Oregon just passed not a law but
they're allowing people to identify as
the third gender on license on their
license when they're you know applying
to get their license no you seen you're
seeing all these little things that are
you know coming coming into the equation
that are allowing people to be a little
bit more you know diverse we write what
they blue is yeah fluid exactly I think
it's important I mean this comes into
play when we're gonna talk about sports
don't line here but not to conflate
intersects with trans like these are
different things exactly that's I think
that's an important thing an important
thing to say because in this is
something that I've been trying to kind
of tiptoe around like is in in talking
about this because I don't one thing I
don't want to do is alienate the trans
community and D legitimize you know what
they're feeling just because it's not
you know from a genetic standpoint I was
genetically born both but that doesn't
mean that someone that wasn't
genetically born you not you know as
they were born or who they were born as
that doesn't take away from how they
feel right just because they don't have
like a you know genetic you know thing
to back it up right yeah there's a
distinction between biology and gender
exactly right exactly where it starts to
quickly get and I'm the furthest you
know from having mastered all of this
which is why I'm a little tentative
about all of it absolutely I really want
to learn and I want to better understand
sure but let's go back to twelve
thirteen you have this doctor's
appointment so are you like
chromosomally are you XY or you are okay
right yeah so it really is this like
merging of the two
yeah in a very unique way yeah it's it's
and it just you can look at it from so
many different angles and I kind of go
back to my entire life just trying to
identify identify and force myself into
this female box rather than embracing
that that masculine side of myself that
male side of myself and you know a lot
of that has to do with society and has
to do with how
were raised and how we come to
understand the world and and if I would
have had you know resources to deal with
being told at twelve thirteen that
you're kind of born both maybe this
would have played out differently having
said that I wouldn't change you know
anything right how about how I played
out and I'm sitting here talking to you
yeah on your podcast about it which is
pretty cool so well it's I look at you
and it looks like it's an almost perfect
blend like a 50/50 kind of thing and it
leaves me wondering whether that's
always the case like is it does it tip
sometimes more towards one of the two
right exactly so what's been cool about
this you know and sharing my story is
all I've had a lot of people who are
intersex and who are born with you know
a variation of a is reach out to me and
so yeah it's it's there's definitely a
spectrum there can be a full-on male
born with a variation of AIS and you
look at him and you would never know you
would never assume that there was
anything different or that they had you
know you know variations of both genders
it's just it can be right and then on
the other end of the spectrum someone
who is visibly very you know feminine
looking could also you know have a is so
it just depends so you're in this
situation where you have a choice
between being a you know a masculine
girl young girl or you know an effete
young male but you've been raised as a
girl you have this test and what's
interesting is kind of what happens in
the wake of you know coming into this
information right like where are your
parents in all of this and like how did
that you know go man
so I went up to that doctor's
appointment with my mom only might think
my dad was working and so we went up
there and did your first of all yeah
started in a rough but like was there
was there any sense on your parents part
like now looking back retroactively Lee
that they knew like something was a
little bit different or was this a big
surprise you know what's funny is so
it's important to the state that me and
my parents literally did not ever have a
conversation about this outside of the
one doctor's appointment in Portland
that when I first found out and then
when we got referred to an internal
medicine doctor in Eugene that day we
talked about it we literally never
talked about it
okay all right yeah anyway what's for
dinner
okay hilarious story so just real quick
I remember we went to that doctor's
appointment in Eugene it was me and my
dad my mom and that was like just a
traumatic experience in itself but I
remember walking out of the doctor's
appointment and me and my dad my dad was
like I think Lakers are playing tonight
oh my god like I'm not kidding that
stands out in my head like huh clear as
day and well part of that sort of cool
like okay you know we'll deal like he's
basically saying it's gonna be okay like
I'm I'm like I'm not gonna allow this to
like color how I see you 100% and that's
and that's how I interpreted it and I
think you know I've heard a lot not a
lot of feedback but just a lot of
questions surrounding you know how my
parents handled it and all that and I
think it's tough I think you put
yourself in my parents shoes and and I'm
the youngest so it's I already have that
you know baby you know complex or
whatever there I'm always gonna be the
youngest and how would you handle it you
know you're a parent like it's yeah I'm
sure you've thought about it and hearing
the story how is you handle your kid you
know coming to the information that your
kid was born intersex it's it's you
there's no handbook there's no like oh
this is what you do this is the you know
the I think in how they handled it I
think it was from a place of protection
and love and just wanting to create a
sense of normalcy for for me and just
kind of you know sweep it under the rug
was was and it wasn't in like a we're
ashamed of this or we no one needs to
know about this because we're
embarrassed about it it was more at
least how I wasn't protecting me out of
protection yeah so I mean I'd like to
think that I would have a super woke
reaction but you know culturally we're
in a very different place right now
those were 20 years ago
Barry so right
it's easy to say you know right now
everybody likes to think that they would
you know do the right thing you know
with whatever terrible thing was
happening fifty years ago right it's
like you weren't living in that moment
yeah Faraday perspective in hindsight
right sure changes a lot so that's
exactly I think you go back 20 years and
it's just the rate at which the world is
changing society is changing
it's insane so 20 years ago was it was a
much different world so right but here
you are you know 12 13 years old and
it's a they don't tell your siblings
right so your parents know it's never
discussed again but you've got this yeah
this bomb that's dropped in your life
where it's like hey you're not a girl
you're not a boy you're kind of both
you're neither you're you're like yeah
what are you supposed to do with that
like you have no there's no counseling
there's no therapy like how are you
processing that as a young person
exactly I think I did everything in my
power just to block it out and not think
about it and I got really good at it
which probably not a good thing anything
in life it's never good to you know
block things out that are clearly
impacting your life and need to be
addressed
I literally just blocked it out right
and you know I'd have I'd have moments
or I'd have I'd see things you know in
the news or hear about other people that
were you know somewhat related to gender
or whatever and it would kind of you
know bring me back to you know a self
realization moment and I'd it was like a
great cause of anxiety obviously and had
to be incredibly confusing yeah yeah
really confusing well also it's
considered like inner-city I was diving
you know and kind of getting ready to
talk to you today I was diving you know
down this like rabbit hole of like what
is intersex and and there's a lot of
pieces that I read that classify it as a
disorder right and right yeah so it's a
disorder it's a disorder I saw that word
come up again and again and again
and I thought it's not really a disorder
it's only a disorder because of how we
socially classify gender right I mean
you're just there's nothing wrong with
you you know just born in a certain way
that's different but that doesn't mean
that you have a disease or anything like
that
and yet there was a protocol right like
you end up taking you were doing
estrogen therapy for a long time yeah
yeah I think that's that's the biggest
thing looking back for me was I remember
at 12 asking a doctor if this was
life-threatening 12 year old asking and
he was like he kind of laughed he said
oh no no you're it's it's not
life-threatening you can go on to live a
long healthy life and it's fine
but I think that was the biggest thing
looking back was and not to throw my
parents it can be life-threatening
though because you don't get help and
you're confused exactly that's exactly
right if you don't have the resources if
you don't have something or someone some
support system helping you walk through
this absolutely it can be
life-threatening
um but it was that's a great point it's
it's you see everywhere it's a condition
it's it's a disorder it's something's
wrong with you and it's that's not the
case right that was the biggest
discovery for me in this whole process
was understanding that actually it's
kind of cool I was born this way it's
it's what makes me unique it's what
makes me stand out and I think everyone
has something about them that makes them
unique and it's kind of about
discovering that and owning it but
that's going looking back as a kid that
was something that I really wish would
have been yeah clearly expressed to me
that Kendra you know what it was it's
great you're born this way you're
perfect just how you are right I was
never rather than being stigmatized or
kind of carrying around this sense that
there's something wrong but yet nothing
that you can do about it exactly it's
like you're gonna go to your doctor's
appointments once every three months get
this injection and that was just always
like just such a just awful thing you
know i I'd go do it and then I'd okay
like three months you know I don't have
to go do that again for three months and
then that three months would fly by and
then the next couple days
I got to go to this doctor's appointment
and that was that was my childhood from
12 till 25 right but now being on the
other side of this journey of
self-discovery of like embracing your
authenticity when you and and owning
your story and kind of owning you know
who you are fundamentally when you walk
into a room and you're like you stand in
your power it's it's kind of [ __ ]
badass it's like who is that what I
never seen anyone who looks kind of like
that like yeah like I'm sure it's it's
there's a magnetism to yeah thank you
yeah I appreciate that so that's it's
funny because it goes back to it's never
about what anyone else thinks or anyone
else feels about you it's about how you
feel about yourself and before I would
you know I'm like 6 1 almost
athletic-looking and so already I kind
of stand out but you know then there's
these other features about me that make
me stand out that don't you know that
people look at and they kind of double
take and and I get that all the time and
before this this you know self-discovery
thing happened that I was I would just
avoid those situations I would just try
and sneak in and just kind of go to the
corner or whatever and not that I enjoy
the limelight really I'm pretty
introverted but it's now it's I own all
this and I embrace it and people still
we were flying down here and and I was
talking you're sitting there waiting to
get on the plane in Portland and Daniel
and I are just like charging our phones
and this couples sitting I don't know
ten feet from us and I can tell they're
talking about me he kind of like
whispers in her ear and I was like in
the mid sentence sentence talking to
Daniel and I was like sorry I got
sidetracked these people are talking
about me and and Dan just like starts
laughing and you just kind of have to
like laugh at it because you don't
really know what they're saying and it
doesn't matter anyway and but it yeah it
is interesting
I think people yeah kind of look at me
or like huh what's going on there that's
that you are Portland it's like the most
progressed I know exactly there's no
there's no better place like really
could be from than in Portland so I'm
very lucky for that so all right so you
start getting these estrogen injections
and the idea behind that is to
like repress the the progression the
growth of like your innate maleness
correct and kind of keep that at bay
yeah exactly
because you know obviously finding out
at that age pivotal you're about to go
through puberty and your body's about to
really change so it's interesting to
think about had I not gone on hormone
treatment what I would look like today
or how my mind would be different all
that stuff but yeah essentially that's
what it was and that was kind of the
goal was or the plan was I guess not by
my design really take the take the
estrogen hormone and then eventually you
know have the you know my testes removed
essentially whatever and that's and
that's what you hear from all these
doctors that that go in and take them
out of these children oh it's what the
kids you know it's cancer risk and it's
like well actually my body's completely
healthy and fine and everything that's
internally in my body is healthy so like
that's not something that needs to
happen immediately or at 18 I can you
know go on and live an extremely healthy
life and everything internally in my
body can be fully functional and fine
but that's kind of what that's what they
do they go put under the guise of oh
well it's a cancer risk so we'll just
take them out and it's like you that's
something I've heard a ton from people
reaching out and seeing my stories well
yeah I was I'm intersex but at I was a
baby they'd or whatever age they you
know about the age that I you know found
out that I was intersex they remove you
know heads right so it's depriving you
of your agency in your choice about how
you want to live in yeah yeah exactly
you know if you want to make that
decision for yourself at some point in
adulthood that's your prerogative but
the fact that it would be done you know
at birth or as a young person doesn't
seem to make sense I know there were
some now there's some intersex advocacy
groups that are really rallying against
that practice yeah interact is is one
agency that I've been kind of in touch
with and they've been they've been great
throughout this whole process and
talking with a lady that it's kind of
the
of that and we had a really good
conversation and just hearing about her
experience she's like I think 45 so I
mean I can't imagine you know being born
in late 70s you know whenever she was
born early 80s I guess would be in the
70s and having you know what I found out
it was it will already was you know not
you know woke you know the you know like
everyone I can't imagine being born in
the 70s and the lack of information that
they had back then you know it's it's
crazy to think about so yeah well you
know this is all happening in a good
time for you yes yeah so what is the
experience of getting estrogen
injections like how does that change how
you feel so I just remember from an
aesthetic standpoint my body I gained
weight I had acne really soft features
lethargic all the time fast like I said
basketball was you know a big part of my
life and just absolutely love playing
and I never I look back on my high
school career and there was never a game
where I felt like my energy level was it
a hundred percent I was always at
seventy-five eighty percent no matter
what and it's not like I wasn't
conditioning it wasn't something I
wasn't practicing you know doing all
these things and so that was a big part
of it just just your overall morale is
just down that's the best way I can
explain it and that's how that's
traditionally how I always felt was just
just not at a hundred percent and for me
it's like you're putting something you
know for an agent in your body that's
not meant to be there clearly I was born
this way and should just be left alone
and I don't need anything else I don't
need some foreign agent you know to come
into my body and get disrupt your
disrupt exactly no regulation exactly
and so yeah it was just not not a good
experience at all and I stopped taking
it I'm I'll be 31 in a couple of days
stop taking it when I was 25 and
from basically 25 on I've never felt
better
I've never felt more energized more
alert just cognitive function just
everything and that's I don't have any
science to back that but just speaking
for my experience in my perspective
that's that's just how I've you know
yeah I felt so well it's great that your
body could still go back to its set
point after after that that practice
going on for so many years yeah that's I
think that's you know a just just speaks
to how amazing our bodies are and how
amazing in the human body is you know
it's it's it's built to last it's
designed to fix itself and to thrive if
you if you give it the right thing so it
is it is amazing well it was interesting
in the video you see these pictures of
you when you were much younger when you
were taking the hormones and and you
look a lot different yeah if you look
very very much a girl and obviously you
know that had a profound impact on like
your not just your physiology but like
how you navigated the world at that time
yeah absolutely
it you know played in to sexuality it
played in to how I saw myself and it's
all it's all connected
you know it's there's you know there's
different you know sectors of the mind
in the body but it is all interconnected
and it impacted the way I felt the way I
saw the world the way I saw myself did
you do like the traditional date boys in
high school thing or kinda I I hadn't
not really and that's another thing
that's really funny is I remember going
back when I was 6 or 7 years old like I
had crushes on girls like there's no
doubt about it and and thinking about it
and that even looking back on that that
was definitely like kind of the first
sign that something was different
something was causing that either
whatever but but yeah I tried to you
know I tried to fit into that mold I
tried to I had an older son have an
older sister and and she you know was an
incredible influence on me and just kind
of helped me navigate and she obviously
she didn't know but I think sisters
certain experiences together in certain
conversations together and those
obviously weren't happening you know I
didn't I didn't menstruate I didn't do
these things that you know sisters would
probably be talking about so that's you
and she's pretty intuitive herself so
she knew something was was different but
didn't you know didn't never say never
said anything who didn't you know fully
understand and but having her kind of
help me and she was so supportive and so
inclusive and just wanted me to be
around her and hang out with her friends
and and at a time where my
self-confidence and self-esteem was was
low
honestly that was huge and it helped she
kind of helped me navigate in a very
difficult time for any youth you know
going through high school or middle
school it's it's a confusing time as it
is let alone trying to navigate being
both genders kind of so right well you
must have gotten some self-confidence
from sports because you're crushing it
in basketball and golf I I'm beyond
grateful for athletics and that's
probably saved my life not that I ever
had any you know moments of just I
didn't have any rock-bottom moments I
don't think but sports were always the
centerpiece of my life growing up and
and had been until I stopped playing
professional golf so in a way it it held
me back in some you know in some areas
of self-discovery but also was kind of
the vehicle to navigate me through a lot
of confusion and almost served as a
distraction which I think distractions
in life can can be positive I think
they're necessary in certain times but
sports yeah saved my life essentially so
what like in high school
what was your crowd like it I take it
you were like a pretty like you know
sort of to yourself kind of person but
like who were you hanging out with yeah
I was I was I like I was but I did I had
a lot of friends and I think and it's
been really cool since this video come
out hearing from people from that I grew
up with from elementary school through
high
and and I I keep hearing the same answer
is you know wow this is kind of makes
sense because we always just saw you as
Kendra like we never liked and I hear
that for my brother and sister I hear
that from their friends I hear from my
friends it's like oh well never really
thought about it we felt something was
different maybe but we just saw you as
Kendra and that's how I feel to this day
and that's how I always felt growing up
and but yeah I did kind of keep to
myself I think kind of keeping people at
bay didn't let anyone really get too
close to me but it was kind of friends
with everyone and and nice to everyone
and and got along with everyone and just
you know just kind of tried to just just
go about my business and was anyone like
I knew I knew all along I knew from day
one like I like you know 20 20 in
retrospect I honestly no one has said
that no the only thing I've gotten is we
knew we just kind of thought you're a
tomboy that's kind of like what I what I
get but no one is and that's what's
crazy so have you ever heard of intersex
or were you familiar with it before you
saw my story no I mean I've been sort of
following at arm's length like the
caster Semenya yeah okay so I mean
that's probably the you know the closest
that I've gotten yeah kind of
understanding yeah so it's just people
just don't know about it and people you
hear a lot about like hermaphrodites and
that's literally not something that is
like a human can't be that means that
you have literally both both
reproductive parts and your you know
that's not something that happens and
with humans so now it's kind of a
pejorative term it is and it's not it's
a very kind of yeah not not something
that you'll you'll hear that sometimes
and it's very yeah not not a welcome
term so yeah everyone is just like oh
wow I didn't know this was a thing and
so I'm what we were talking on interrupt
yesterday and in front of you know 50
people and so I was like had anyone
heard of intersex or you known an
intersex person before you saw my video
and like three people raised their hand
so they're like or they think it means
trans yeah see that's that's where it's
you know it's it
just they do get kind of lumped together
and there but they're you know obviously
we talked about they're extremely
different so this whole process has been
it's been educational for me because for
a lot of my life I didn't even want to
think about it
I didn't want to research it I didn't
want to hear about it I just blocked it
out and so even for me you know doing
research and learning about it as I'm
you know telling this the world my
stories has been crazy but hearing from
people whether it's strangers or friends
wanting to know more and wanting to ask
questions and that's that's what I want
you know at this point I mean I'm an
open book and I want you know want
people to be educated so you go off to
Oregon for college and you play golf and
you're killing it right like you clearly
super talented golfer you have this
crazy long swing right like that's what
you're known for yeah and I read a
little bit you know a couple articles
and people were like yeah I mean Kendra
could just go into any tournament and
win when she put her mind to it but
there was always the consensus or it
seemed like people were saying you know
she should have gone further with it
like there's no reason why she couldn't
have been just absolutely killing it on
the on the on the LPGA Tour so there was
something holding you back right yeah
so walk me up you know walk me through
this experience of playing golf in
college and going pro and what happened
yeah so I I just have a very weird
relationship with golf I always have
basketball was always my main sport was
always my true love and I think part of
me always feels like I wish I would have
taken basketball further I could have
played both in college and also just
play golf in the in the form of being
practical I guess and and and with the
idea of turning pro after college which
it's just funny because when you when
you look back and think about how you
view age and view the world when you're
in high school going into college you
think you have all this time and you
think oh that's you know five years away
I'll figure it out
after college and looking to turn pro
I'll figure it out then and it goes by
quicker than you think and so I always
kind of just went along with this idea
that I play professional golf and I just
do it and and then with that I have this
you know huge thing going on that I
haven't addressed in my entire life so I
just you know I just kind of delayed it
and just let it be and just kind of went
along this this path of oh y'all turn
pro and so I go play in college for four
years and do really well and I'm working
towards this goal that's everyone thinks
is my dream that I'm gonna go play in
professional golf and be on the LPGA and
I just kind of go along with it and but
it wasn't really your dream no it really
it really wasn't and I think I think
it's interesting to look back and think
about how I would have viewed golf
differently if I would have just been
born or athletics in general how did you
been born you know a fully functioning
female none of this extra baggage going
on how I would have dealt with it and
and what I would had I been born you
know fully female what my goals would
have been how I would have viewed the
sport and and you know how I would have
navigated that but so yeah I had a
really successful college career won
tournaments placed well all-conference
all that stuff and had a fifth year it's
at school afterwards my senior year
didn't end very well and I was kind of
burnt out on golf so I was kind of
thinking about my options but I was like
well I need to try this I need to you
need to turn pro and and see you know
where this goes
meanwhile just still refusing to think
about you know the the underlying issue
of gender was there a sense that someday
you know that moment that reckoning
would come or were you operating under
the idea like I'm just gonna hide this
forever so I figured I figured one day
they would it would come out and I think
always in the back of my head I knew
that it was going to get to a point
after I turned pro that
I was either gonna have to fully face it
and and and come out to the world and be
like I'm I was born intersex I'm gonna
continue to play professional golf and
I'm gonna figure this out and the
governing bodies we're gonna have to you
know because they have rules and
regulations set in place and we're gonna
we're gonna figure out or it's gonna be
the reason I said away from golf mm-hmm
and it ended up being the latter so I
just knew that I played on the symmetric
to referred for two years I had status
for another another year before I
stopped playing and I had a little bit
of success not a lot and kind of what
you what you're speaking to just people
being like I don't know what's going on
there like she has all the tools you
know she has everything to make it to
the top and there's there's something
going on there there's right and I had
my swing coach who was a fraternity
brother and my dad's in college actually
who I had worked with you know as a kid
and into college and Anessa Pro he was
interviewed for a golf week or article
and and he said something like I always
questioned her mental strength I I just
figured you know she didn't have a lot
of strength and he obviously didn't know
any of this about you know the way I was
born and and he was like you know and
coming into this knowledge about how she
was born I you know I can't imagine how
how mentally tough she is so I think
that's I always I always felt like I was
mentally weak because that's what I
heard from people like why aren't you
producing why are you shooting these
numbers why aren't you progressing to
the LPGA you have all these you have all
the ability in the world and are you not
passionate about it or you don't have
the work ethic and it wasn't that it was
this underlying you know issue of not
addressing right well a you're not a
fully integrated person like you're
you're you're in denial of your true
essence yeah so in a game like golf
where precision is everything that
dissonance can't help but affect your
game
exactly and that's something that I I
don't think I ever took into account
that this issue was affecting every
aspect of my golf game of my
a personal life it was 100% especially
with in a game like golf where you have
so much time to think about things and
process things and the reason I like
basketball was so much was because I
could just rely on my you know inherent
athleticism and ability to just react
and not think about it and golf I had
that all the time in the world to think
about everything and not a good thing
yeah thinking yeah that's not gonna help
right exactly like golf's all about
trying to not think yeah exactly
and that's some of the best golfers are
just able to just calm their minds down
and just go out there and and and be
reactive and just just play right so you
have that going on but I think at the
same time like I look at it as a fear of
success really because success would
mean ultimately that this secret is
gonna come out and it's not gonna come
out on your terms
100% it's exactly what it was fear of
being successful and because that would
100% mean that it was gonna come out I
remember I qualified to play in the US
Women's Open and I was like terrified I
was gonna get drug tested and they were
gonna find you know even though I was
still in estrogen they were gonna find
higher levels to of testosterone and I
was gonna get you know outed and that
was like a horrifying experience I
played awfully at the Open and it was an
incredible experience because the US
Women's Open but I was in back my mind
I'm just sitting there like waiting to
get tapped on the shoulder come with me
we got to go right in a cup so yeah you
could have called a press conference
though and you come out with it yeah I
know right and just kind of just out of
myself and just and just brought on the
storm and it's just you weren't ready
exactly
exact witting golf and then it was it
was it around that exact same time that
you stopped at the estrogen treatment
yep yep and so what was that decision
all about um I was just I was just tired
of the way it was making me feel the way
what it was doing my body I weigh like
I'm 6-1 I weighed I don't know
160 something like that
and I was you know 180 185 and I mean I
was working out and stuff I was healthy
I wasn't you know doing anything
estrogen made you gain weight yep yep
when it's supposed to keep this hormone
at bay yeah that is associated with
muscle bulk yeah I like yeah absolutely
I I don't know you know I'm sure there's
there's science behind it or you know
whatever but it's it was almost not
instant but as soon as I stopped taking
it I'd leaned out I was able to put on
more muscle mass it sort of makes sense
but I think my frame just in general is
more obviously more of a lean frame so I
just got kind of got back to my
basketball now exactly I'm gonna go do
an open tryout yeah just just place
that's well actually when I stopped
playing golf I actually went and you
know joined the city league in Portland
and played a bunch of basketball so that
was like so fun I don't do it anymore
just because I'm just I don't want to
you know tear an ACL or Terran Achilles
over you know an open gym so and how
long did once you stopped the estrogen
how long did it take for your body to
kind of reach a stable set point I would
say probably a year yeah yeah probably a
year that's kind of when I really
started to notice a difference you know
sort of physically and mentally was
about a year so and the fact that you
made that decision tells me that you're
inching up towards you know a
willingness to own this finally I think
so um and you never know like was there
something that prompted that occasion oh
yeah yeah yeah I met someone last summer
uh-huh yeah that that completely flipped
my paradigm another percent yeah when
that person was like what are you doing
or were you honest with that person so I
met her last June yeah June 2018 in
Portland and she knew right away
something was something was different
something was but it was was totally
accepting and
it's just fun excited obviously didn't
tell her right away like I still hadn't
told anyone and it led I think I told
her actually told her on my birthday
2018 which was sort of been like a month
and a half later we had an open
conversation about it and she was like
yeah can I already knew and I don't care
like I think you're I think you're great
I think you're perfect how you are and
and it's so funny because I you know
growing up I always kind of imagined
what that conversation would be like
with the first person that I told and
just kind of fearing their reaction or
fearing you know being denied or being
just made to feel less and we as humans
I guess we sometimes you know always
fear the worst or think that the worst
thing is gonna happen and is the
complete opposite it would happened and
it was like oh okay well that went
pretty well maybe you know have a
conversation with it about about this
with my family
yeah well the scarier thing we sort of
assume like we're afraid of what all
these people are gonna think but I think
in your case it's really about having to
then own this essential truth about who
you are like that's the truly terrifying
part of it exactly that's you can hide
behind like oh I don't want the
judgement of other people oh yes the
self judgement it's not what exactly
it's it's it's never about what anyone
else thinks or feels about you it's
always about how you feel about yourself
and for my entire life I didn't
understand that it was always oh I'm
afraid of what people are gonna think or
what people are gonna say and and I
think you never know what event is gonna
prompt you to kind of own yourself or
whatever you know situation it is for me
it was meeting someone and being being
told that I think you're great I think
the way you're born is really cool
that's what it was for me and so it
could be meeting someone it could be an
event that happens to you it could be
you know situation that you're in you
never really know what it is gonna be
but it it is always within you and maybe
it just takes something to bring it out
yeah and the next kind of phase is when
you you
a couple letters right mm-hmm so how
long after that yeah so I think I wrote
that letter to my family when would have
been that would have been September no
yeah September early summer so it was
probably three or four weeks after after
I uh I had had that first conversation
and that was i sat in a coffee shop in
Portland and actually typed it and write
it it would have been cool to be
handwritten but would have been really
long typed in a coffee shop and just
kind of unloaded on it for three hours
and and sent it off to all of them and
and yeah the phone started blowing up
probably from everyone so my brother he
was living in Hollywood at the time my
sister where is she I guess she was she
was living in Portland as well and and
my parents were in Portland but yeah I
kind of dropped that that bomb on them
and and my parents and talking to them
you know in hindsight they're like yeah
this was always we knew this day was
gonna come we just didn't know when it
was gonna come and we wanted to be on
your terms so mm-hmm
when you look back on how they parented
you through that do you have misgivings
like do you feel like I wish they had
known this or had done this and how do
they feel about you know how that whole
thing way I think from my standpoint I
don't I don't have any any real feelings
towards them at all I think because I
know how they acted was from a place of
protection and love that was always the
attitude I got from them in regards to
this it was never like I said it was
never you know we're ashamed of this we
can't tell anyone were embarrassed by
this it was I could just sense that it
was from a place of protection
I think they and they haven't really
been open with me about how they truly
felt and dealing with it I think they
had a lot of guilt you know as you get
older and you can kind of start to see
through you know what your parents tell
you in kind of like all the right lines
or not that's you know that's BS but I
just feel like it least at one point
they would have been like Kendra you
know
that thing when you were 12 like are you
okay like how's it going yeah like can
we do we need to talk about it it's like
it's crazy right there's somebody that
you want to talk to you know yeah we
help you like never is going on and so
it never happened yeah which is crazy
and from the outside I can I can see why
people like what is going on they're
like why why was that like not even like
hey Kendra like you know that time when
you were told you were born both genders
like how are you doing with that I mean
we were like wait did that actually
happen yeah I got like some dream that I
had it was like an out-of-body
experience it was like transporting to a
different realm and just like oh wait
did I just hear that right like I'm on
both huh so so yeah I think I think they
they they harbored a lot of guilt over
it like you're cut you're like a you
know like you're like a superhero or
you're you're not the Avengers who are
the ones that all go to the school the
mutants Oh Dino the Teenage Mutant Ninja
turn the one with the guy in the
wheelchair
you know the superhero movie you know a
lot of kids that are different and they
go to the school and Ionis that called
yeah you're kind of an x-man yeah yeah
but like we're not gonna talk about yeah
exactly file that away and you're
exactly exactly
it's funny because I was having a
conversation with with one of my buddies
his name is Mike he was saying like you
know what your story really reminds me
of this this this animated cartoon that
I used to watch and I don't remember the
name of it but he was like this cartoon
had all these cool superpowers and never
felt like he could tell share it with
the world because he thought that
everyone would think he was weird and he
was embarrassed about it but really when
he did tell him it made everyone like
him and think he was just coolest thing
and I was like that's yeah that's pretty
cute right well I'll go with that I
don't have superpowers but I'm both
right so and just to be clear like I use
the word mutant because that's what the
x-men that's the vernacular of the x-men
I know yeah I'm not saying that in the
context of being in her side
okay totally like please don't have
alright alright but you write these
letters and it sounds like they're
pretty well-received right like you're
loved by your yeah please and get
errands and all of that yeah so how do
you go from there to now you know kind
of being public about this
yeah avoiding YouTube comments avoiding
comments and USA Today articles well how
did it on interrupted project come
together we should say like
uninterrupted is the digital production
company of LeBron James remember Carter
yeah did they approach you or how did
they know so it's happened it's a crazy
story actually so after I had that
initial conversation it was kind of
tossed the idea was kind tossed around
like hey you know you should really tell
this story publicly and I think it would
it would help a lot of people and I was
like yeah like I'd kind of just hold my
family and but how did they know that
whoa
well who said like I'm confused so did
they reached who reached out to him
right right so this the idea that I
would maybe approach some some media
mechanics he would you know and approach
him like hey I have this story I want to
share with GB and shouldn't help me tell
it so at first and I won't name the
media company it was another kind of
athlete geared media company I
approached them and said hey well first
I reach out to a friend who I thought
might have a connection there and so I
told that friend who was like the second
third person you know that I'd ever
shared my story with it's like hey do
you think this is something they might
be interested in telling he was like I
think so let me get in touch with my
friend who's an editor there so was in
touch with that editor for like two
months and the process just was really
slow it wasn't going I didn't feel like
it was going anywhere and I was kind of
getting frustrated and I ended up
telling Daniel who's here with us today
my friend my story and I had told him
was like you know I'm talking to this
media company about sharing this story
you know on a platform but it's not
really going anywhere I'm kind of
frustrated and he was like well I have
this friend who works it uninterrupted
you should reach out to them and see if
they would be interested in sharing
I think they would so he gave me his
friends contact information and I wrote
an email and said hey this is my story
would you guys be interested in and
helping me tell the world about it and
he was like definitely and I'm it was
almost like the next day I was on the
phone call with Jimmy Spencer the VP
there and a creative director Camille
who I worked closely with throughout
this whole thing and they were
incredible so that's kind of how that
you know that kind of came in into light
and and that was in December of 2018
right so you you guys shot this quite a
long time ago yeah yeah exactly
I think the first time we filmed was
March and then they came back up in end
of April to shoot again so it was from
December basically until July 8th I
think it was the day it came out it was
it was pre production filming
post-production and so I was yeah it was
a seven-month process right it was well
it's beautifully done great they did
they I mean just I can't imagine like a
more compelling and graceful way to
introduce your story to the world
yeah yeah super super grateful to
interrupt it for for allowing me to
share this story and it's not like I'm
not a clearly not a household name I'm
you know a golfer from the Symmetra to
her so it's like I didn't have that
clout you know to back it up but they
saw they saw value and sharing a story
like this and I think the uniqueness of
it and I'm just I can't really put into
words how grateful I am towards them
and just not only allow me to share the
story but how they handled it and how
they they knew it was a delicate subject
and just involving me in areas that they
probably usually don't allow when
they're working with an athlete but just
because of the the delicacy of the of
the subject they they included me a lot
in you know in sort of the the shaping
of it and and how it was presented and
just yeah I don't I don't that I just
yeah I've all amazing things to say
about about I mean it's not really a
video about sports exactly an athlete
exactly it's it's I yeah I had this
crazy story and I also happened to play
golf and and that was very much so
that's kind of how we wanted to
to frame it as well as it was you know I
played golf at a high level but this
this other part of it is way more
obviously the the centerpiece so so that
was like five or six weeks ago when this
thing yeah yeah was published in the
world and there's been you know a fair
amount of media in the wake of that the
USA Today Golf Digest or you know
there's been a lot of articles out but I
would imagine it's been a pretty
tumultuous topsy-turvy last six weeks of
you now being foisted you know by choice
by design you know into this place where
you're now you know associated with what
it means to be intersects and and the
focal point of conversations that are
taking place around this subject
particularly in the context of sports
and being an athlete totally I think and
that's that way and obviously whenever
the story was gonna come out I knew that
that was the the direction the
conversation was gonna go was okay well
this is great but should you've been
allowed to compete right and that was
always what I was most afraid of and and
yeah it's like I said yeah try to avoid
looking at comments from you know on
these publications but I you know do
take a peek and kind of see what people
say and and it's tough it's it's a it's
a it's a complex issue and you know we
talk kind of touched on Castro earlier
and I don't think there is one easy
solution or
you know right answer but just yeah just
kind of being now looked at as sort of a
voice for for this this you know gender
and some more you know topic and yeah
it's it's tough it's it's well you're
new to suddenly being a mouthpiece for
this exactly and so the sense that I get
is you're trying to work all this out in
real time but everyone's looking to you
now to have an opinion about these
things and you know I just know as
somebody who
has a very you know arm's length
relationship with kind of what's going
on in this world
I have knee-jerk reactions where it
seems very black and white and even in
preparing to talk to you today like I
really did some research into this world
and the more that I learned the more I
realized it is much more complex and
nuanced than even I originally imagined
and I thought that I had a pretty good
grip on it yeah yeah exactly that's I
think to your point I have been kind of
figuring this out as I go and I don't
have an official stance on you know I'm
very much so formulating like because
all this is still extremely new to me
I'm like I said I'm still doing your
research I'm still figuring out about
myself and and what this all means and
and like you said people kind of you
know want me to have a stance on it and
stand for something and and it's tough
because I'm just I'm not there yet and
I'm you know I'm still figuring it out
and I think I kind of just go back to
the idea of you know inclusion and at
the end of the day that's that's the
direction I think that we as a society
are going we as you know athletes and in
the sports world in general going you're
starting to see way more inclusion and I
think just sort of bending the way that
we look at gender and in and how we you
know it's not black or white it's very
much a spectrum and there's a lot of
gray area but with that it's it is a
complex issue and it is something that I
think both sides are gonna have to make
compromises English in the short term at
least it's super difficult like
basically what it is is a human rights
issue that is budding up against the
interest of fairness and sport and it's
a gender identity issue that is also
budding up against traditional ideas of
fairness and sport and how you reconcile
all of these things to create you know
not an even playing field but a playing
field that we can all wrap our heads
around that seems at least fair yeah
right there is no good immediate
solution and it's interesting that
you're this you know this this coming
out
you know July eighth when this video
comes out I mean it's right on the heels
of May ninth with this big meet where
where you know some how do you say loss
many semenya yeah caster Semenya you
know competed at this event and is
really challenging these new regulations
and rules in track and field that are
requiring her to lower her testosterone
and you know from what I understand her
medical records are sealed but there's
there's been leaks and the kind of
consensus is that you know she's
somewhere on the intersex spectrum I
mean if you have pictures over yeah it's
not a leap right you know imagine that
that's the truth totally and so what
does that mean as as as an athlete who's
competing at the highest level I mean
she won gold in 2012 in 2016 in the 800
meters going into 2020 now being forced
to take testosterone reducing drugs in
order to create some you know basic
fairness and the sport like I don't know
that lowering testosterone is the right
way I understand the sentiment behind it
like she's a beast right and if she is
intersex is that fair like I don't know
the answer to that and we don't need to
you know come to some determination of
that we're gonna throw it out right now
but I do appreciate the complexity of it
and I can very much see both sides of
this argument
totally it is tough it's like you said
it's it's like first of all who who
decides that this level of testosterone
is like so someone set this this level
that she's above or whatever that's the
acceptable level and it's like okay some
some person set that that said okay well
this is this is the quote-unquote norm
or whatever the case is and she actually
just got barred from I don't know if you
saw it from competing in the World
Championships she can't defend her title
right yeah so it's an appeal but the
Pele was denied yeah yeah so I think
like you said in the short term there is
no there is no immediate answer there's
there is no matter which way you go one
party is going to feel like they're
being you know give him the shaft or
however you want to phrase it so and
like you said it's like is is the
testosterone level is that what is that
the determining factor as to why she's
so great or why she's so dominant in the
sport right so it's like yeah I think
there's questions around that in terms
of how the science breaks down I know
that you know whether you're your double
X or XY is a big factor in how your body
processes testosterone testosterone
isn't the only thing but I think
fundamentally this is a person who was
born a certain way in the same way that
you you are and her argument is like
look I've been a woman my whole life
right this is how I was born if I'm
naturally higher in certain aspects of
of what it means to perform at the
highest level at what point does that
become unfair and the example that keeps
getting raised is like well Michael
Phelps has this incredible wingspan and
yes got giant feet and hands and should
we make him you know get surgery to
reduce the size of his hands because
he's genetically gifted in a way that
other people aren't yeah it's trickier
with gender and sex though it is and it
that someone actually asked me that
question yesterday uninterrupted and
this is a deeper topic that we don't go
into but I do think it is because she is
female and the way we not we but society
views strong dominant females I think
you look at the way I brought this up
yesterday the way Megan Rapinoe has been
treated and and how she's been labeled
you know she goes and celebrates the
goal and she's oh she's so egotistical
she's so arrogant and it's like her male
counterpart goes and does that
Christiano Ronaldo goes and celebrates
the goal and everyone racing ever
exactly so it's like why is there this
double standard so if there was a male
athlete who just had crazy high levels
of testosterone just nobody would say
well that guy needs to take needs to
lower his to take some estrogen like
yeah it would be celebrated like oh he's
such a yeah like and it's a precedent
it's a broader conversation about not
just gender and sexuality but also
fairness and sport right you know where
do we draw these lines and you know we
all want we all want some
once of fairness but but what does that
look like and what does that mean and it
breaks down when we get into this
terrain there was a really great episode
of Malcolm Gladwell's podcast
revisionist history where he talked
about this with respect to two pitchers
baseball pitchers one who forgetting
their names eyeshadows but like one who
had a surgery to repair whatever the
rotator cuff or whatever it is I know
I'm totally miss recalling this but
that's totally fine and went back to
normal and the other pitcher who got
some it was steroids or some kind of you
know injections that were just used for
medical purposes to kind of enhance the
healing process so he could get back on
the mound and that person became a
pariah Fred you know so we have we in
and and that's you know that this is
this is too like dudes yeah in Major
League Baseball now imagine intersex and
you know all of these other issues that
get thrown in there in all of our biases
and historically how we think about
these things it just becomes like almost
impossible to have a cogent discussion
about it exactly I I kind of go back to
the idea of how are we evolving as
humans and I I attribute a lot of my
athleticism obviously genetics but also
having an older brother and having you
know playing against him and him
roughing me up and having to raise my
game to meet his level so it's like and
this is another example it's like right
now in the WNBA there aren't a ton of
women who are dunking basketball at ten
feet right so I've you know there's on
Twitter or whatever there's in the past
there's been discussions well should we
lower the hoops to eight feet to make
the game a little more exciting or how
should we handle that and it's like well
what happens if we lower the hoop to
eight feet we're not going we're not
going to you know continue as well
continue to evolve as humans someday at
ten feet there's going to be women who
are throwing down the basketball all the
time I don't know how far in the future
that is but that's gonna be because you
set a level we will meet it so it's like
what are we saying if we don't allow
caster or anyone who's intersex to
compete if they identify as female
they were born female if we bar them I
think we're we're doing the greater you
know good a disservice I think allowing
these people to compete will maybe not
tomorrow in a year or two but maybe five
ten years down the road it is going to
raise the level of competition in my
opinion mmhmm yeah that's hard yeah
because I I can easily see the others
yeah exactly the look I was if I was an
Olympic 800 meter female runner right
and I see caster I'm like yeah I can't
compete with that that person is is is
fundamentally different for me right
there's a jersey characterized as such
there's there's there's components of
her that no matter how hard I work no
matter what I do I will not be able to
compete and all you do is look at the
times yeah like there's so much better
yeah and then track especially it's like
like her numbers are like astronomical
like in terms of like distances of the
you know what she wins by is you know in
Traktor I think if that me to may she
beat the American record holder by like
four or five second right which is
insane no like so but then you looking
back on your career as a golfer like
there has to be some aspect of you that
you know has to own the fact that you
had an advantage there share some
benefit to being wired the way that your
wire yeah that allowed you to be
successful yeah yeah and I think like
the how far hit the golf ball is is is
definitely it's definitely one thing I
the the longest hitter probably any tour
if I were to go out right now and what's
funny about that is it's great it's
great to the ball you know really far it
can also be a great detriment Symetra
Tour typically plays golf courses that
are shorter and tighter which for
someone that hits the ball a long way is
an advantage it's actually you know I'm
so many times I would only hit driver
one or two times there and around I'd
you know constant behaving like to iron
off the tee or 3-wood and and
essentially taking my greatest weapon
out of my bag because I'm not gonna hit
driver on a hold short narrow because
the chances I hit in the trees are you
pretty high so not to say that this is
like a disadvantage but Golf is funny in
that that something that can be viewed
as a huge advantage can also be a
disadvantage but absolutely they're
looking at the way I was born and how it
put me in a place that other women that
I was competing against simply wouldn't
be able to get to no matter what they
did that's an advantage and that's
something that yeah I do have to accept
and an own and that's a part you know
that's a whole part of this yeah how do
you think about all these things in the
transgender to athlete community because
then it becomes even harder to wrap your
head around yeah it's I think there has
been a couple cases in the Northeast
somewhere where there's been transgender
boys who identify as girls have been
allowed to compete as girls and track
meets mm-hmm and you want to talk about
a sticky subject that yeah I think I
think it goes back to kind of what I was
talking about earlier about how just
because I was biologically born this way
or genetically born this way it doesn't
make how I feel internally more
legitimate than someone that was born
fully functioning male who identifies as
a female I think when you involve sports
it obviously makes it extremely
difficult and tricky but from a human
element it doesn't it doesn't make my
case more legitimate because I have
science to back it it's I think it's
just it's just about people having
compassion for people and understanding
that you truly don't know how someone
how they are feeling on the inside or
what they're going through and you you
need to respect that but yeah it's it's
a it's a difficult subject yeah it
really is I mean this is this is a
situation in which I really want to
fully understand all aspects of this
debate and that's argument and maybe it
is because I'm 52 years old and grew up
in a different time yet to me I look at
the clear-cut cases like a transgendered
woman who
in combat sports or powerlifting right
and those seem to be you know people who
have undebatable advantages right and
it's odd to me that were debating this
at all but then you know I watched a
little mini documentary on Vice about
this powerlifting transgendered woman in
JC and you know she looks at it as a
human rights issue yeah and she feels
like she has met all of the sort of
regulations right she was supposed to
meet and took her testosterone reducing
drugs and you know all the like and is
adamant that she should be allowed to
compete and I have a it's a harder leap
for me to see her point of view yeah
than it is for me to go look you if you
if you were born and raised male and you
developed you know a certain bone
density and musculature and all of that
and you you transition to female and
then you go into the boxing ring or the
cage and you're in an MMA fight like
it's it almost seems unsafe and and and
certainly unfair yeah yeah I think for
me it's it's definitely a case of seeing
both sides to it I think you have to
look at it from from both points of view
and imagine imagine yourself as you know
a fully functioning female you know
growing up and what that entail is how
your body develops and the physical
disadvantage you have compared to a
fully functioning male you grow up your
whole life you do all these things you
reach the top level you know in MMA and
all of a sudden you're standing you know
in the ring with someone who was born
fully male and transitioned to female
from that person's point of view I
yeah I'd feel I'd probably feel a
certain way about it I think because
these rules and regulations are in place
and requirements that okay if you're a
male and you want to transition and keep
use of you know this is this is what has
to happen this is these are the steps
you have to take I mean that's it's the
best they can do right now right
and I I just don't it's it's so hard to
come to a definitive conclusion on on
who's right who's wrong what's what's
the best way to go about this and kind
of like I what I said earlier was both
sides are gonna have to compromise and
in in this idea that inclusion has to be
the number one priority and everyone no
matter how you're born how you feel what
you identify is there is a place for you
to compete at the highest level in
whatever and whatever Avenue you go down
participation in sports is you know a
human right yeah and I certainly don't
want to be somebody who would prevent or
bar anyone from you know pursuing their
love of sport
and I think you know it's gonna be
interesting to kind of watch this unfold
over time and I would say to anybody
who's listening to this who is
transgendered or intersex or has a very
different point of view on this yeah I'm
open and willing to learn like my ideas
on this are evolving totally it's just
kind of where I'm at right now as
somebody who's barely glanced at this
issue so I don't want to assert that
like I have a firm grip on this and that
yeah you know I have an ironclad yeah
you know opinion like I I'm I'm open and
I want to learn more that's and that's
like that's the most important thing is
that you know people and that's that's
what's wrong with our society in general
is people just like nope this is the way
it is is how I feel about it and I'm not
change my mind it's like if everyone
could just have an open mind and be open
to you know different possibilities we
would get we'd make a lot more progress
than we do the problem is I think the
overwhelming majority of people are you
know close minded and aren't willing to
shift their the way they view things or
the way they feel about something
because of their experience and growing
up or whatever the case is and but I
totally agree I think as long as people
have an open mind we can we can
eventually I don't know when but we will
eventually get to a common ground where
it where everyone feels seen and and
things are as as fair as as they can be
no I don't know well here we are you're
six weeks out from you know sharing this
publicly
I mean you reached out to me like you're
wanting to tell this story and to share
it so
can't help but presume that that there's
some aspect of you that wants to be you
know if not a role model like somebody
who is in this conversation you know in
service to other people who are you know
struggling quietly with what you had to
go through yeah I think I look back to
myself as a 12 year old and and you know
I wouldn't I wouldn't change how this
how everything played out from when I
found out until until this moment
sitting here with you but I do think
that a big motivation for me in telling
the story and coming on
you know this podcast and and sharing in
other in other areas is to be a voice
for for kids or adults who are
struggling with this or struggling with
any sort of identity or whatever they're
going through and that there is a
platform for you to be seen and to be
heard and how you're born and how you
feel is validated and it is legitimized
and and just you know so much of life is
just finding commonalities with people
and being able to relate and I remember
the first time I met up with someone for
the first time knowing that they were
intersex going into this meeting it was
something I'll never forget it was the
most incredible experience for the first
time getting to relate to someone in
person that has gone through the exact
same things as me so kind of taking that
and putting it on a platform that
obviously I can't meet every single
intersex person to ever exist so and not
every intersex person to ever exist will
see this story but the more that I can
share it and put light on it hopefully
the the more corners of the world it'll
reach and you don't have to be intersex
to relate to my story I think I think
everyone is going through something
internally that you know they or
something of a bay feel on the inside
that they don't feel like they can share
or you know talk about or or identify
with this is the stories for them as
well and whatever you're feeling on the
inside it's you know it needs to be
respected and it needs to be addressed
and you you will always have people in
your life that are that are willing to
sit down and hear you so what is the one
thing that you
you you don't want that person to hear
who you know who is dealing with this
quietly I think what I would have wanted
to hear is that the way you're born is
is perfect you're perfect just the way
you are we live in a society that that
tells us there's there's two genders and
there's there's roles within those
genders and you know I I think to forget
about it don't don't worry about it
you're unique you're perfect and just
own it I think if someone would have
told me that at 12 years old when I just
found out I think that would have made
it a pretty profound impact on me maybe
not immediately but in time and I think
I would have been in a place where I
kind of could have dealt with this
before I turn 30 but yeah I just think
that no matter what no matter what your
genetic makeup is no matter how you were
born you're perfect just the way you are
well it's interesting times right now
yeah because now we are talking about
this in a way we never have historically
you know the subject of of transgender
rights is you know first it's front
front and center more and more people
are coming out and there's a broadening
of understanding on these issues why do
you think this is happening now it's not
like yeah because interesting yes
exactly exactly this has been going on
yeah the whole time but it's only now
that we're really dealing with it yeah I
think I think you know the world around
us is getting smaller because of you
know social media and and people are as
are as close and as able to communicate
as quickly as ever and I think people
are yearning for that that sense of
community in that sense of identifying
with other people that are like-minded
and I think that's that's the single
driving force behind this and it's funny
because the person that kind of changed
my you know kind of helped me flip my
paradigm you know I was like a you know
interpersonal connection but people are
you know reaching out to all corners of
the earth trying to find people that are
like them or like-minded and
you know you go back even even ten years
ago 15 years ago people weren't as
connected as they are to this day so I
think you know people are finding out
that oh there are a lot of people out
there that think like me that are like
me like we deserve to be we deserve to
be seen we deserve to be heard and I
think you're seeing people kind of grow
that that confidence and that that self
that that sense of you know I I want to
put myself out there and I think that's
it's a beautiful thing and I hope that
it only continues and I think it will
only continue yeah well we need more
role models and and people that are
willing to step out yeah you know into
the end of the spotlight and kind of own
this in a public way and we are seeing
that slowly like it's amazing I don't if
you watch billions no I don't do it as a
plank Taylor on that show I mean their
performance in that program is it's
really a game-changer yeah it's really
quite something because you can't take
your eyes off them like the performance
is incredible yeah there's so much
charisma and it's such a bold character
in the show a pivotal character and to
see that like writ large in a very
prominent well-received television show
is is not a small thing and I think
we're gonna start seeing more and more
of that that's kind of my hope it's like
there's I don't in a major you know film
there's never been an intersex character
right which when that happens will be
the coolest thing ever like I think just
there's thinking about everyone that
will see that and come to at least get a
elementary understanding of what being
intersex is that's that's gonna be a
huge day and like you said it is coming
I think we're we're you know hurling
down this road of inclusion and shedding
light on all these things that our
generations generations past have you
know put under the rug so right well
education is everything it is and it's
like look you know intersex is a new
thing for a lot of people was for me and
it is important to not conflate it with
the transgendered community it is a
different thing I mean there's obviously
overlap in that Venn diagram but it's
its own distinct thing what do you think
people most misunderstand about
you and who you are and what you stand
for that's a really good question I
think I think people probably like I'm
sitting here in my entire life I've just
felt normal like I just feel normal I
just feel like a human I just feel just
how I am and I think people in the way
there's some of the things that they've
said they they almost come at it from a
standpoint of wow you must feel like an
alien or something you must feel like
really different or and I do in some
areas but I do just like I think that's
any topic in life is you know whether
you're a different race or a different
gender or whatever is you just feel you
and you just feel human at normal and I
think people from what I've you know
conversations I've had I think people
think I feel like an alien or something
like it from a different planet or
something but I don't I just I just feel
like kinder I just feel normal and I
think people don't understand that they
have this preconceived like yeah you
must feel really different and it's like
no I just
I'm just Kendra I just you know well I
would imagine you feel better not like
more comfortable in your own skin now
because you've owned this completely
yeah you've you know communicated with
your loved ones and now it's a public
thing and you're standing in that right
so there's none of that dissonance and
you know there's no longer a secret
that's like a roading you know a year
exactly your insides and all of that
like it I would imagine there's a sense
of freedom that even you know a couple
years ago you couldn't access yeah it's
just total liberation that's the best
way I can explain it it's it's amazing
just in hindsight looking back and
seeing how in every aspect of my life
this affected me and in areas that I
didn't even realize I mean every single
aspect of my life this this thing was
looming over me and I got really good at
blocking it out and pretending it didn't
exist but subconsciously of course you
always know that it's there and I always
just had like this this anxiety about it
like this this cloud or that I was and I
was like this I was hiding something and
and it was almost
something that I was you know 24/7 every
single day you know all parts of the day
aware of it was you know kind of
subconscious but and and that's just
disappeared it's just it's gone and that
is like everyone deserves that and like
I said there's varying degrees of what
people are going through but I'm sure
everyone has some sort of element to
something they're going through that if
it if they addressed it and let it be
free they would feel this way and
everyone deserves to feel this way and
it's just it's almost like an
out-of-body experience so yeah it's it's
it's pretty it's it's pretty great and I
don't want everyone to feel this way so
I have to ask you I want to be like
respectful of boundaries and I don't
want to be insensitive but I'm just no
real sound really like this might seem
frivolous but I'm interested in how you
figure out how you want to portray
yourself to the world like do I wear a
dress like you're wearing a black
t-shirt yeah but you're wearing earrings
yeah it's like yeah there's this mix
yeah or maybe like do you play around
with that like how do you figure out
what your aesthetic is yeah because this
is the forward facing yeah this is how
the world receives you so I would
imagine there's some intention and
thought that goes into that
yeah very what you're what I'm where I'm
wearing Khan's black jeans and black
shirts is pretty much all I wear I wear
you and me both exactly it's like this
I've got like 10 black t-shirts yeah
that's pretty much where I were yeah
that's yeah and that's something that we
can we have a commonality we can relate
to which is cool like regardless of
gender you know so yeah just kind of non
not that I identify as non-binary at
every let me just say like for me
personally like I don't feel strongly
about like that like I'm not like yeah
but I've so many times people been like
okay what are your pronouns and I'm like
uh-huh for me personally I just yeah she
her of course but like I don't know I
don't feel really strongly about it and
I don't know what that means or whatever
I just do you feel pressure like you
have to you have to be like a social
justice warrior in a way that doesn't
feel authentic to you that
exactly couldn't have said it better all
all I can do is in trying to be
authentic is is speak to how I feel and
I guess it's like not like because my
whole life I was trying so hard to put
myself in a box I think that's a part of
it that now I'm like I don't want to be
put in a box I don't like I would never
I would never identify as non-binary and
and and be referred to as they or you
know whatever nor would I want to be
called he you know but it's your
prerogative yeah that's the whole point
exactly you choose exactly and if people
feel strongly about that and they want
to then they have their pronouns I think
that's awesome
whatever whatever is authentic to you do
it that's that's my message really just
just be authentic whatever that looks
like
and so like for me authentic is is
skinny jeans Black team and some cons
that's and if I could wear that the rest
of my life all I'll be happy so well you
can exactly it's a free world right so
that's that's that's the goal so where
do you go from here
you're not playing golf anymore right I
think you you mentioned before we
started the podcast that you're doing
something with Nike golf now yeah yeah
so I just accepted a position with Nike
golf last last week it's not actually
fully official but kind of is so
hopefully hopefully what is that doing
what so it's a brand manager role and
it's it's kind of unique role in that I
think you know they're kind of looking
to bring someone on that has a different
perspective of the golf industry the
golf consumer someone that has played at
a high level and I haven't you know I'm
not super well versed in the corporate
world I just never happened and my my
skill set is sports and I have a
creative background as well and I think
they were kind of looking for someone to
come in and bring in an offer a
different perspective and point of view
and that doesn't have that that history
of that that corporate background so
that's kind of what you have like some
background in photography filmmaking
like a branding yeah crown as well yeah
and I think that was you know that was
something
that was enticing to them as well and
and I didn't get this opportunity
because of the story but I think and
that was kind of expressed to me that
that is something that makes my my
profile unique as well and so I think
they're just kind of looking for for
someone to come in and shake things up
and offer something something different
so yeah I'm really excited about it and
like I said I was in Ikea fleet when I
was on tour I played when they were
still making golf clubs played Nike
clubs in college and went to the U of O
which is of course where it started and
right so I've kind of been kind of in
hand-in-hand with Nike at real life so
and and how do you think about this you
know evolving role as you is this sort
of mouthpiece spokesperson yeah you know
role model I would imagine you're
getting opportunities people are wanting
you to come and speak and yeah I think
that's something that that's on my radar
like I said like it's tough for me
because I think yeah I think you made
this point earlier was people are
looking to me to have an opinion have an
official stance and feel very strongly
you know very much one way but in a
funny way it's like I'm almost coming
out from the standpoint of I don't
necessarily want to be black and white
on this issue because we live in a world
where there is so much gray area and
maybe that's kind of a comedy matically
no it's perfect because you're not like
your whole thing is like defying this
duality and being non-binary yeah like
so how could you be binary on the issue
it might not quite and parcel of your it
is there are so many like metaphors and
you are literally grey yeah so your
perspective is correct yeah exactly
I couldn't doesn't work for people
though they want you to like you we want
you to come speak but here's the line we
want you to toe and yeah that's kind of
you know how culture is functioning
right now in in a in a not good way
hundred percent and that's so that's
yeah going forward I think I do want to
be someone that is looked to to offer an
a perspective on what I've been through
in mind my life and and like I said I
think I obviously want people who were
born intersex that may be going through
something similar that I did to look
story and find solace and feel validated
I also wanted to relate to people who
are just going through anything in
general that they feel like they can't
talk about or can't live out so in turn
you're not gonna you're not gonna see me
in rallies you know protesting in front
of courthouses and stuff like that
that's just not who I am you know it to
my core
like from a standpoint of being
authentic but my whole thing is just
just just inclusion and I will continue
to continue to talk about inclusion
wherever this takes me in whatever
platform I have and right
I just inclusion and compassion that's
that's really the two main things for me
so how's the dating going oh you're not
the answer Wow on the spot not we just
say fine or not or whatever laughing no
I'll just be honest I mean I think my
life has been has been crazy in the last
in the last six weeks and in it you know
basically when this process started back
in December I really just secluded
myself from the world you know Daniel
can probably talk to me you know just
coasting and just not being available to
hang out and it was such a it was such a
weird time going from December until
July from when it came out just almost
feeling like I could like because this
was going on and I was gonna be hanging
out with people that I wanted to tell
but I couldn't or I didn't know if I
should I did kind of seclude myself and
I think a lot of this in coming out in
in the last few weeks and moving forward
here in the in the near future is you
know opening myself to to people whether
it's friendship relationship whatever of
course I want that I think you know
everyone everyone wants that but and I
think when you do open yourself to that
the universe kind of you know provides
that and so that's it that's what I'm
hoping at least what I tell myself well
I'm excited for what's to become with
you I think your your story's superpower
for all it's important it was very
courageous of you to
own it and come out in the way that you
did and I really appreciate you sharing
it with me today and I think it's gonna
be a beacon of light and hope for a lot
of people out there
so in closing are there any resources
that come to mind like if somebody's
listening to this and and and they're
relating to you but they feel alone like
are their therapeutic resources are
there certain websites that you know of
that I can put in the in the show notes
or that you can mention now where people
can go to learn more yeah if you just if
you google interact that's that's a huge
resource that was actually I was made
aware of a few months ago but in in this
story coming out people from interact
reached out and said hey like just want
to introduce ourselves like we have we
have cells you know kind of all over the
country we have a cell in Portland and
you know community where you can reach
out and you can you know connect with
other intersex people I think that's
that's the the one for sure so you just
Google that that'll kind of you know
find your wherever you're located it
should have should have resources there
sorry I provide so and if people want to
connect with you yeah I just Instagram
Twitter at Kendra underscore lit so
li-chee t li TT yeah to tease this so
there's there's a few Kendra littles out
there okay broke there's like a software
engineer and there's a designer funny
story it could pops up when you google
you tender little another Kendra little
reached out to me after you saw my story
and she was like hey never heard of you
this story is amazing whatever I was
like oh cool two weeks later I'm looking
at her Twitter profile again she lives
in Portland no way yes I was like I
tweet her I was like wait how did I miss
that you're in Portland as well so I I
don't know the you know many Kendra's in
your life like it lovely kendra little
that is pretty crazy so she's in
portland so maybe we're talking about
getting coffee so alright yeah yeah your
folks okay yeah they're happy yeah
they're great yeah they're actually
moving back down to Eugene which is
which obviously where I grew up and my
sister just this baby's so my mom's
gonna be in heaven down there helping to
raise those so so yeah I read
everything's everything's moving in a
positive direction so cool well
everybody listening check out the video
the undefeated video all probably one of
Charlotte's about us our uninterrupted
why I say undefeated
defeated a sneaker store uninterrupted
I'll put the link in the show notes to
that everybody should watch that and
come back and talk to me again sometime
thanks so much for having me on super
grateful she ate it thank you I feel
okay awesome
good amazing we did it yeah we did it it
was cool yeah all right thank you so
much
[Music]